hello everybody markiplier here we just
had 500,000 subscribers which is
absolutely incredible
I never thought it would happen this
quickly and I was thinking about it and
for the fast few past few milestones I
did something funny or out of the blue
to try to celebrate it but for this one
it's so important because it's literally
half a million people that have thought
that my channel was good enough to
subscribe to and that's that's an honor
that's something that I need to treat
with respect and I wanted you to speak
clearly on how grateful I am that so
many people have believed in me and
decided that I was someone worthy of any
sort of praise and that's a humbling
feeling so sincerely thank you guys for
being with me here and I am able to come
down here to South Carolina to do what I
originally wanted on YouTube which is
make sketch comedy videos and creative
stuff like that and I'm not saying Let's
Plays aren't creative but in all honesty
it's not what I wanted to do I do it to
the best of my ability I'm going to keep
doing it for a long time but I want to
be so much more I want to be up like the
best entertainer I can be for you guys
and I want you guys to be with me as we
keep going forward and you have been
you've been supporting me more than I
ever thought possible because you've
literally been telling everyone about it
we've been getting over 3000 subscribers
a day we've been growing at an
astronomical rate we're getting more
than a hundred thousand subscribers a
month and that alone is just an
absolutely incredible fact I had a goal
that we were going to hit a million by
March of next year and now if the pace
keeps up we're gonna hit it in like
November maybe even October I don't even
know but it's gonna be way sooner it's
all because you guys have been
supporting me so thank you guys so much
thank you everyone that I've
collaborated with thank you yamimash for
being a great friend of mine and doing
the news Thank You cyndago for like
making me come down here and do videos
with them because they've been awesome
and inspiration for me really they have
and they've taught me so much on
filmmaking and
and thank you manga minx cinnamon toast
can oh there's so many names of bad with
names but miss Monica have there been so
many people that I've been lucky enough
to collab with and if I forgot your name
is so sorry I'm terrible with names but
just remember that I am so grateful for
every one of you guys who have been
supporting me all the way so sincerely
from the bottom of my heart thank you
and we are going to go forward and we're
gonna hit a million whenever we do and
then we're gonna keep marching forward
and I'm gonna try to bring better videos
to you every single day so thanks again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
okay that's pretty good idea I think I
hit all the time